what's going on guys this is rob and
this is the last video that i am
recording before i go on a cruise for a
week and we are back with another
installment of our beyond omega level
series and this is where i usually say
this series is where we break down the
most powerful characters and comics but
this week we're doing things a little
bit differently and we're stepping out
of the realm of marvel in dc and into
the realm of nickelodeon as we cover
aang from avatar the last airbender so
aang was created by series creators
michael dante dimartino and brian conroy
whose name i can't pronounce and first
appeared in the series first episode in
2005. now since there might be some of
you that watch my channel regularly but
are not familiar with avatar the premise
is that there are four different types
of vendors that can control the four
forces of nature fyi mariah's here
checking to make sure that i don't screw
anything up
she's the only person i know who's an
expert on avatar but these forces of
nature are air water earth and fire now
there is at any given time one
individual called the avatar who can
bend all four forces and is in charge of
keeping peace throughout the world so
when one avatar dies the avatar spirit
is reborn into an individual from the
next nation in the line of succession so
if the avatar is from the fire nation
when that avatar dies is the fire nation
mariah is the fire nation or fire
kingdom fire nation when the when the
so if the avatar is from the fire nation
when that avatar dies they'll be reborn
as an air nomad then as a member of the
water tribe then as someone from the
earth kingdom and it just starts over
from there so when avatar roku who came
from the fire nation died aang who was
an air nomad became the new avatar upon
its birth now when the air nomads found
out that he was an avatar aang was still
a baby but he was taken to the southern
air temple so that he could be trained
by the monks primarily a monk named
uh how do you pronounce that name right
gyatso okay so he could be trained by
gyatso who served as aang's mentor and
father figure now eng displayed
exceptional prowess at airbending and
became the youngest master in the
history of the air nomad at age 12 which
was also the age he was informed that he
was the avatar so no pressure now he was
also told that he'd be sent from the
southern air temple to the eastern air
temple separating him from gyatso which
prompted him to run away on oppa his
flying bison now aang and appa get
caught in a storm and seemed destined to
drown in the water where they crashed
but aang is able to access the avatar
state which we'll talk about a little
bit more later and he encases himself
and oppa in ice where he would remain
until they were discovered by katara and
saka of the water tribe over a century
lady now as you probably gathered from
the title of the show aang is also the
last airbnb the reason for that being
that the fire nation attacked the air
nomads and then wiped them out
completely shortly after aang was frozen
and this was part of an attempt by the
fire lord sozen to take out the air
water and earth kingdoms which plunged
the entire realm into war that lasted a
hundred years and would settle the
conflict for the animated show that
would basically deal with it as we get
into aang's powers
we'll start with what he's best at which
is of course air bending which is simply
the ability to control the air now as i
said earlier eng became a master
airbender at age 12 making him the
youngest master in history now aang uses
air bending in a variety of ways some of
them not very surprising like using it
to fly with the aid of his glider
created tornadoes but there were also
plenty of instances where aang used air
bending and some really creative ways to
do some really creative and impressive
things for instance on one occasion when
aang and his companions attempted to
rescue a group of earth vendors being
held by the fire nation in a prison that
was basically a big platform made of
metal in the middle of the ocean so that
they wouldn't be able to use their earth
bending powers since there was no earth
around aang cleverly solves this problem
by using his air bending to project the
coal used to power the prison facility
to the surface of the water where it
could then be used by the earthbenders
to defeat their captors and gain their
freedom on another occasion eng was able
to use his airbending to redirect and
cool down lava preventing a town from
being destroyed by a volcanic eruption
which i didn't even know was possible i
mean i guess if we knew that you know
the best way to deal with the lava flow
is just a really strong breeze but even
though air bending was aang's first
skill and the one he was best at mariah
is getting so irritated with me
but even though air bending was aang's
first skill and the one that he was best
at as the avatar aang was the only
person in the world with the ability to
bend all four elements however he needed
to be trained in order to learn those
skills now aang was naturally gifted at
water bending initially being trained by
master paku at the north pole and then
by his friend and eventual wife katara
after she becomes a master now aang did
not use water binding particularly often
but he was able to reroute entire
waterways and create tidal waves
although he was aided by the moon spirit
when achieving this feat which is kind
of a weird set of events apparently
soccer's girlfriend became the moon i
mean i don't know like how do you
explain that to someone i mean i guess
he kind of did when he was talking to
that one chick who was a kyoshi warrior
but i guess like i mean how do you
explain that hey like so so you know i
just got out of a relationship really
like what happened my girlfriend became
the moon in all seriousness though aang
was also able to alter the density of
water which was a skill that few if any
water benders possessed now earth
bending did not come naturally to ang
because the personality traits of that
skill at least what it required which
was being stubborn and unyielding were
completely foreign to him aang was
taught by his friend toff who was a
beast toff was op but he eventually
develops this skill for earth bidding
which allows him to manipulate basically
anything made of stone or earth and he's
even able to use this ability
blindfolded due to the fact that his
teacher toff is blind and passed that
skill onto him in his training now the
final skill eng learns is fire bending
as for a long time aang refused to learn
the skill because when he first started
he'd inadvertently injured katara and
vowed never to fire bend again after
learning that the true meaning of fire
bending is connection to the sun life
and energy instead of simply just rage
aang agrees to learn fire bending from
zuko who's the prince of the fire nation
and one of the greatest characters ever
made in the history of fiction if i
could get away with it i would do a
beyond omega level video on zuko he's
not really beyond omega level i mean
maybe we can just cook the books and
just be like beyond omega level zuko he
gets that title because i just want him
to have it and it's my channel and i can
do whatever i want i feel like zuko fans
are like works for me like i think it'd
be cool right so regardless aang was
even able to learn the dancing dragon
technique one of the most difficult fire
bending techniques that had been
believed to be lost to the ages aang was
also able to use his fire bidding
abilities to single-handedly take out
fire lord ozai's entire fleet of ships
although his strength was increased by
the presence of susan's comet which
boosts the powers of all firebenders and
it was legit when he did that okay what
really sets aang apart from others
though is that he was able to master
energy bending now energy bending which
ang learned from the lion turtle which
was literally just this giant lion
turtle out in the ocean is an ancient
form of bending which affects life force
energy rather than any of the other four
elemental forces and so energy bending
which is a skill only mastered by a
handful of avatars allows its user to
take away the bending abilities of
another as aang did with fire lord ozai
which allowed him to defeat the fire
lord and effectively bring an end to a
century-long war now for those of you
guys who never saw avatar the last
airbender it was a pretty legit scene
right when like he he basically has like
fire lord ozai like locked down right
he's like held in place and then aang
just like puts his hand up to his head
and there's some stuff you know where
it's like you have to make sure his you
know his anger doesn't overpower you and
like all that all that nonsense but aang
just like literally strips this guy of
his ability to bend and i was like man
that's why i couldn't be the avatar man
because i would straight up be a villain
like some somebody out there would like
mouth off to me i'd be like what did you
say and it's like i said you're a crappy
avatar rob and i'd be like you know what
you don't get to bend anymore and like
that would be the end of it and i would
just conquer the world like i would i
could not be the avatar but all of you
guys who watch my channel you already
know that anybody who's watching this
who's been watching this youtube channel
long enough knows i'm a villain man i'm
i'm the bad guy in the comic book story
i would straight up just be a villain i
don't know what to tell you but
nonetheless back on track in order to
energy band aang has to enter the avatar
state which allows him to convene with
all previous avatars now aang is vastly
more powerful in this state but
achieving it requires him to unlock
seven chakras or energy focal points now
aim freezes through the first six but
struggles with the seventh which
requires him to abandon earthly
connections which his main hang up being
his interest in katara right like he was
digging the girl and so eventually aang
manages to unlock the seventh chakra and
achieve the avatar state so definitely
within the world of avatar at least aang
is clearly beyond omega level as he's
one of the most powerful avatars that
has ever existed and he basically has
total control of not only the four
elemental forces of air water earth and
fire but also energy itself so having
said that guys let me know what you
think down in the comment section should
we cook the books and just make a beyond
omega level video on zuko i mean i guess
maybe within the avatar universe he's a
mega level i don't really know he never
mastered the ability to bend lightning
but he could channel it so i don't know
like maybe we can find a way to make it
work or we just call it beyond omega
level and we say like he's not beyond
omega level but we want to do a video
about zuko so here you go i don't know
what to say maybe we do that i don't
know let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section thank you
all for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace